hi I'm mark Walton and welcome to
another gamespot news update fable
crater and former head of lionhead
studios Peter Molyneux has said that EA
is not an evil empire and has in fact
done a great deal for the video games
industry Electronic Arts is yet again in
the running for worst company in America
but the battlefield and mass effect
publisher is not evil according to fable
crater Peter Molyneux EA is not an evil
empire he told kotaku they're a company
that have done a great deal for this
industry but when corporates by
companies several things change Molyneux
has an intimate understanding of what it
means to work with EA as he sold his
first studio bullfrog productions to EA
in 1995 one of the problems that came
along with the acquisition was what
Molyneux called love abuse when EA
bought bullfrog they just wanted to make
it nicer they moved us to a nice office
where we couldn't shoot each other with
BB guns in the corridors Mollom you said
we had an HR department because that was
a nice proper professional thing to do
and that changes the flavor of the
company when any company is acquired
it's gonna change the company Molyneux
added sometimes that change can possibly
make the company better lots of times it
can make it worse malini would later
establish fable developer lionhead
studios which was acquired by microsoft
in 2006 he quit Microsoft in 2012 to
open his own studio 22cans which is
currently working on goddess for more on
goddess check out a live demo from the
man himself on this week's episode of
the lobby and for all your video game
news just keep it gamespot